this is Startalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we have an
exclusive interview with the one the
only Kelly Clarkson you should have the
button 40 old virgin Kelly Clarkson in
the house on Startalk the meaning of
life when you say it like that it's far
more dramatic that's kind of bodacious
audacious yes to be calling your
household it was bold you can figure out
the meaning of life when you buy my
album it's great so important like
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory golden
ticket Wow okay so that means I don't
get to learn it oh no not so you get it
I'm just saying so the meaning of life
is this something you figured you've
known for a while I just came on to it
no I mean I think we're all under
construction and I think at the point of
me doing it under construction we are in
yeah and I think the people who are
fully built no longer learning anything
well and that's first of all any person
that thinks they've got it figured out
completely is a total dork it means they
really haven't figured it out because
they haven't figured it out that they
haven't figured it out yeah whatever
you're a philosopher no I do I think
that I think that meaning of life is is
really just about connection and and
making sure they're positive connections
you know there's people to people yeah
but how about all the negative people
who are out there you know you just like
push them outside your bubble and you
know I do I have a tattoo for that
pastor too much people have an app for
that well cuz I really needed the daily
reminder her we're in an industry when
people can be not so lovely and so I
have a tattoo 'no pastor told me this
knows a kid and I loved him he was like
one of those people that you wanted to
you're like what do you have in your
life because I want to be like you like
he just had a light about him and and I
just thought he was special and he said
one time that you know there's gonna be
people in your life and it's easy to
love the lovely people but it's not easy
to love the unlovely and and
that was really poignant and I thought
that you know you have to love the
people that are unlovely even more
because they weren't loved enough so hmm
missing something in life yeah so I
don't know I think it's about just you
know trying to make this positive
connections and and and really I think
it's simple I think we complicated as
humans because we try and figure
everything out and sometimes you can't
you know but you you're what sometimes
you can I can't your mother was a
schoolteacher so who you are making it
part of your life's mission to figure
things out and at school teacher that's
what they're trying to get their kids to
figure stuff out yeah how much of this
Jen touched you I love I mean she always
taught me to question and I think that's
the best part of whether you're talking
about faith politics life any you know
love it's always to question it like it
so I love that I love to question
whatever is happening in the moment one
to make sure it's real and and and to
just because I don't think when you stop
questioning then you stop asking you
stop caring right I don't know I can't
say it better than that I bet you can
effortlessly no I think the word I would
use is curiosity
yeah is what yeah without that you you
can't be a scientist yeah no I I agree I
think that's that's the fascinating
thing to outsiders like us that look at
people like you like because you we're
curious but we're constantly in that
state and you're actually figuring it
out you're curious and we go figure it
out man I'm glad you figured it out I
was just sitting over here being curious
it reminded me I was giving a lecture
one time and someone things I'll never
say that's amazing but but in that sense
we do share space because I give
lectures in theaters and so and I feel
like the theater stage is sort of
sanctified but yeah the artists all that
came before me yeah and I feel the the
artistic energy there it's an
interesting but so I was there and I
mentioned something about the universe
and someone asked
so where did you get that information
it was great I don't mind that yeah and
they said where did you look up that
information I said I calculated right
and people think that like a wiki page
is like handed down from God no I'm your
Oz behind the curve I'm the the class of
people who write wiki pages is what we
do Wow somebody got mine wrong I was
Catholic for quite a long time so you've
got kids of your own
are you are you sort of channeling your
mother's teacher energy and how you're
definitely yeah I am exactly like my
mother in a lot of ways yes in good ways
well you turn into your mother no there
are moments whenever I'm like
disciplining my children and I'm like no
God my mom but no I sort of it yeah the
education side of her I definitely am in
the one in the household that the kids
maybe don't like as much because of that
I'm constantly making sure they're
reading that's a big thing because we
have a lot of younger kids like you know
so I think that that's where it starts
and and because one thing I didn't know
or appreciate until I had kids and
surely you see this that kids our
children are so curious yeah that the
curiosity can actually kill them if you
don't intervene oh my god even reading a
simple book like we were reading a book
last night my daughter hi princesses
wear pants and like literally she stops
on every page in questions every bit of
everything and I'm like we're losing the
story where you're focusing on all the
like things that aren't really the point
of the world is so alive to her yes but
everything is new so you sometimes it is
nice to slow down but but also it you do
have to intervene to be like yes but
don't interrupt every time because
that's rude so let's finish the story
then we'll discuss okay all right so
this is a lesson plan
save your questions for the end I was
the nerd at the front of the room well I
I think too because I knew I would talk
mm-hmm if I didn't so that if they had
to look at me and I felt bad
so I have to be quiet what were your
favorite subjects in school I loved
literature just cuz I love reading and I
loved I don't know I loved I was an
athlete I loved drama
I loved all the electives you know like
quiet about that and there's not a crew
to your GPA
no I'm definitely like that part of my
brain like but I did like I didn't like
history because you had to memorize all
the dates cuz I just liked focusing on
the point of it like I liked focusing on
the not repeating it but learning it but
the dates were always like I wasn't ever
good with date I've never been good with
numbers
so I nor I with regard to dates but I
remember relationships or correspondence
so I remember for example that
Shakespeare was around with Queen
Elizabeth the first yeah and they were
around at the same time as Galileo where
he's figuring out the universe I'm
saying yeah nor did I ever read that I'm
looking at a minute
I'm yeah that the two things yeah and so
once I did that then that put it all in
context for me who's of course they're
in different countries you know there's
England and Italy but but it's a way to
help me navigate yeah exactly that's
interesting because I would have thought
Galileo for his older like I would have
thought of different way long ago in
fact there's books they're called
timelines of history where it's just
timelines it's a timeline and it's like
that cliff notes for time watch what it
does so so that first the first row is
like so across the bottom is time yeah
the top is technology politics Wars
discoveries inventions and then you
could do a vertical slice through it and
see what everybody was doing across the
world in that one slice wait what is
this great it's called timelines of
history okay I would totally be into
that yeah yeah so just check that if you
like reading like reading and you like
language and words I'll and you wrote
two children's books yes which was very
different from writing songs what was it
before you had kids are after it was
after I had kids after Huck a night well
cuz I literally just started writing
them for my daughter really just to kind
of cut knew she wouldn't remember all
these amazing places she's going and I
thought if I put the pictures with these
little stories she can when she started
learning to read it could be her her
little story and then my my husband and
my nanny were like you should make these
into children's books and I was like all
right and and then and then I thought it
was gonna be very easy and it was not so
because the poetry in which you write is
completely different than how you write
four songs and how kids take it in like
and how you have to almost play with the
words and how it has the meter is just
has to be just kind of very perfect and
people go to school for that so I you
know my editor was very helpful yeah
that's what I found I think you can
write a sentence but to write a better
sentence you should be thinking about
the rhythm of it and yeah and the
juxtaposition yeah on the page and does
this word work following this word yeah
and how long did you drag someone in
that sentence before you should like
stop are they bored are they bored right
and the the difference between great
writing and just writing is everything
there yeah not that that's got me
thinking I can read a poem on a page or
rhyme and it'll mean something
informational II to me perhaps but if I
hear you sing it there's a whole other
conduit of communication going on oh
definitely and are you you I you must be
self aware of that and you can go in
there and you can ya lated you how are
you how do you grok that um you know I
think it's I don't even think about I
think I'm just so I've always been
touched by music even before I knew I
could sing I love dancing I loved music
I it was a safe place for me it was like
it was just a it was a whole different
kind of learning you know just with
people's lives or whether it was you
know rock rap pop like country whatever
you were listening to it's you know the
music is very good indication of the
time in that time line that you're
referring to
music if you look at it it always
follows it because we're obviously
artists are affected by our you know
nature and nurture a bit so yeah it's I
don't know what's your goal you know you
can reach people emotionally but you
also would have the capacity in a song
because a song is a story yet to reach
people informational II yeah I mean you
want
your balance what's your bet I'd like to
be a you know throw a bit of you know be
a bit poetic but at the same time keep
this story simple enough to where people
aren't focused on the words of the story
it's more focused on the feeling of the
story
it's more focused on what what what that
how that made me feel and how that cuz
I'm more of an emotional person I just
go out and read a damn book too many
words
yeah and it's I don't know I've always
been the one to focus more on like I
always feel like okay I know I talked
about Meryl Streep a lot but my point on
this sure I know but I'm just saying I
do talk but here's my point I've never
said this before but it's like I love me
some Meryl Streep oh but I feel like
she's one of those people it could be a
silent movie and she would effortlessly
flawlessly dictate by her her emotions
her eyes just her every part of her you
would know exactly what she's saying
without her saying anything through the
entire movie I think she would have been
like the most fantastic silent actress
as well because she's got that art to
her whole like physical body her
emotional state and her eyes like in her
mouth and her you know all of that
whether it's Miranda Priestly or
whatever character she's playing and I'm
The Devil Wears product yeah so he
shorts like whatever those are she does
so much and I think that as a singer to
like that's what I try to do like with
songs I try to like you know whatever
the words are I could be not saying
words and just singing melody but by my
intensity or by the modulation of it is
my emotion yeah you could almost tell
the story I'm saying without even hat
there being words like that's my goal
that's not that I achieved that this
mural does that's beautiful that's
that's I think not enough people know
that or feel that or understand that
yeah it's almost like you want
everything because you have everything
if you focus on that and then you put
amazing words to it and then you put
amazing you know set behind that it
becomes this amazing show that people
you know you want all those things to be
firing on all cylinders
can I tell you something about you that
you might take for granted
okay so tell you several know just it
was just a quick thing that happened to
me yeah
that leaves me wondering whether is a
state of existence for you rather than
just a thing that would happen yeah so I
was not to get morbid on you but I was I
witness on September 11th because I
lived very close to the clock and I was
there my window the buildings collapsed
people John it was it was and and I'm a
pretty stoic guy and after those days
and just that event I was my rational
brain was no longer operating yeah and I
was just feeling everything yeah and you
almost didn't know where to put it and
it was it was spilling anomie and I
would see someone slightly sad in their
emote in their face and I was like oh my
gosh can I bring them flowers can I can
i yeah what can I do and I'm just
wondering you as an artist that makes
you a great human well I judge by the
way and my writing over that time was
better I think yeah and then as I was as
time went on and I began to lose it the
writing was kind of went back to what it
used to be and I'm just wondering was
that moment that I experienced something
that you live as an artist well I think
a fair question yes and I think that we
I think artists of all kinds painters
sculptors writers singers whoever I
think we all go in and out of that the
capital a artists yes but I think we all
go through that and what you do with you
know as an astrophysicist is it is
almost that's an art like it's a form of
art like that I don't get but it is for
you so I think any time you're we always
have moments where we're really deep in
it and then we have moments where we
love it but it for some reason it's not
affecting us as it normally does you
know I think we always have those like
tug of war like rollercoaster things but
and the bad thing about it is I think it
was sting I heard sting to an interview
at one time and he was saying you know
it's it's sometimes it's horrible
writing a record because it's the most
miserable high like it's the most you
know draining period because you're
you're wanting to be a vessel for all
these messages and you want to do the
best you can but it's you know an
actor's say that a lot they get so you
know they delve into these characters
and they get lost in it and it's a it's
a catch-22 you want to do that but at
the same time you don't get so far gone
that you can't even help yourself you
know so but I mean I don't know I go in
and out of that but I will say every
time I every time I perform even if I'm
sad and or tired or you know just
exhausted or overwhelmed or whatever I
still I'm incapable of not going in
I still when I perform I always I'm
always in the moment like especially
since becoming a mother it's just like
emotionally 100 yeah so I'm just saying
that was my one okay one moment yes
because it cuts you down to like your
courts where you're just so vulnerable
yeah yeah and it's a beautiful thing to
be vulnerable but it's exhausting yeah I
was I was that's a good word vote I felt
vulnerable which was odd just as a
scientist um usually yeah there's how
that works and I know how that works I
got this cleanable yeah that's I was I
was I was hit hit by that so when when
you're singing but when you're writing
or when you're choosing a song are you
thinking okay this will get them this
way is this emotion and this will more
selfish oh I know I'm more selfish about
it it's not only about the listener it's
more about what cuz I find that I'm a
very normal human being like I might be
the judge of that
well I live a very low-key life in
Tennessee like I'm not like I don't have
like a normal pulse star live so I don't
know I find that I'm very similar to two
people I'm not like unique in a lot of
ways so like if I'm if I'm listening to
a song and I'm touched by it I feel like
if I am then other people will be you
know so it's more or less like it's my
it's my favorite thing that my old
record label would do they'd you know
send songs and it's like kind of a song
and they're like oh but you you would
sing it so well and I'm like well I'm
not concerned about that part concerned
that it's not a good song like but it's
like one of those things when you I want
to be moved by it I want to be the
vessel for something powerful and and in
a moment you know you only get so many
records so you have certain freedoms now
at Atlantic yes like trial freedoms but
yes yeah yeah people don't you
average person on the street don't just
give me your song and I'm not gonna yeah
I don't care who publishes it so the
meaning of life is your eighth album yes
and now forgive me I haven't heard all
your albums yes but I heard this I'm so
offended but this one I've heard you're
the stuff that is charted off of those
albums of course I've heard those in
this album it is it's there's a
soulfulness to it yes that but it has
sort of pop roots bringing soul into it
and I'm when I'm old enough to I'm
trying to remind of we would they have
put this album in the stove-piped
categories in a record shop yeah and I
don't think there's a spot no I mean
it's I guess a pop pop just because no
no you know there's too much soul excuse
me because you sing and I just have to
stop what I'm doing and just where's a
pop song you can keep cooking you can
and you shake to it but you're not moved
by it moved by a pop song yeah that's
why it's pop because everybody likes it
yeah it's popular its popular right but
if it's another kind of you made it you
know it's it is soulful pop and I it's
definitely there's definitely a
difference when you listen to this album
versus the other albums I mean one you
can just I'm happy in it and it creates
a whole different that happiness creates
a whole domino effect of different
sounds and tones and and and and even
the freedom that Atlantic has given me
creates a whole different vibe because
an artist in the in their form to where
they're able to just go okay well wait I
could do whatever I want but luckily I
love I was telling my husband this like
even before the album dropped I was like
I've literally been waiting so long to
make this musical footprint that like
even if it didn't do as well as other
things I love I love that like I'm still
happy at the end of the day for that you
know cuz I've been very blessed I've had
15 great years of success and even if it
were over me like I've had a phenomenal
career and I'm very thankful but it is
funny and ironic that 15 years into my
career I make my favourite people think
that everyone's first album is going to
be their best or their most significant
yeah and if not then they don't sign you
or they no but I mean I think there's
wisdom there's physical intellectual
emotional maturity there's life yeah and
yeah my favourite aretha records didn't
come out till way in der excuse me on
first name basis didn't come out until
really after she signed with Atlantic oh
really
okay yeah it was another reason I loved
just the label in the nostalgia of it
that's her amazing grace so do you think
of your voice as an instrument that
needs cultivating and care and yes okay
yeah no I have to ask as we were in the
green room before you performed in the
YouTube yes base and I loved it that
they call it space yeah if you've got
space in your room I'm good with it but
before you were like just yucking it up
with everybody in the green room and
just walk out there and then out comes
this this wait is how do you wait how
well I warmed up earlier this morning so
I I oh I worked before I've been working
since this morning so I definitely I
definitely aim to warm up every day it's
just like a speaker like a public
speaker like your your voices or a
runner your voice is a muscle you know
it's these little things that you have
to keep trained and I know if some
singers don't have to I think I've heard
Jennifer in an interview Jennifer Hudson
she said first name people I will start
names off her first name
okay if she does walking yeah okay my
turn my turn okay yeah you're in a
different pool no I'm saying she's well
yes and she's she's a big vocalist and
she doesn't she said in interviews I
found it shocking she was like I don't
warm up at all it just happened so I'm
not like that I have to I have to warm
up a bit there I can do it it's just not
gonna sound as good okay no not to call
you out but you are 15 years older than
you were when you an idol so it can you
is the warm-up the same oh yeah he's
here
yeah I think you know it's funny I saw
Tony Bennett no no no that's fine it had
both names Tony and he's saying and he's
you know 80 something and I was like I
mean he killed all of us like he he was
amazing and I'm a Tony Bennett fan but I
was you know I don't know I thought
maybe the older we get like I don't know
sometimes people sound different he
sounds even better like a fine glass of
wine it's so beautiful and I will say if
you're if you're doing things correctly
and you're taking care of yourself
and you're not ruining your cords you
know you're not ruining your cords not
getting Naja you're not doing things
that you're not supposed to be your
vocal cords or your musical chords
you're here people have enough surgery
of all that stuff if you're taking care
of yourself I think that you get better
with age this your voice sounds more
lived-in and it sounds like I can go
lower I can go higher I like that phrase
lived in yeah like a good pair of boots
yes my favorite voices aren't like mine
my favorite voices are stylist and I'm
not a stylist like like I love Bono I
love Annie Lennox I love Reba level even
a refill like there's a style to them
like I love so many different genres I
think that's why I'm not a stylist like
I like to float but and that's clear
yeah
I love love - yeah many artists yourself
included have certain issues with
society that you that you want to change
that you want good what's your short
list of those oh gosh I mean
open-mindedness yeah my gosh yeah I mean
just overall the thing is a huge problem
especially when you've children it's
even magnified you know it's magnified
even more so I don't know an overall
open-mindedness and just that whole
thing that you're taught when you're a
kid like putting yourself in somebody
else's shoes I think if we literally did
that more often and imagined it was a
direct impact to our daily lives we
would we would be more open minded so
what I wonder is sociologists like study
this stuff and I wonder if the real
solution is just to get people who are
well known to just be the champions of
all these things that society needs and
doesn't know that they need it I know
it's really funny though because every
time an artist says anything you get the
shut up and sing we just wanted to hear
you sing we just want to see you play
football we just want to see you yeah
I'm just saying it's like it's always
like a we just like like as if we have
the one thing that makes us us like and
I think the important thing is I try not
to get mad at that and I try and have an
open dialogue whether it's social media
or and meet-and-greets when I meet
people or wherever I am and I try to
keep an open dialogue and an open mind
because you're not going to change
someone's heart by returning their hate
with hate so so I you know I try to be
positive and I try to be comedic you
know have a comedic timing about it kind
of thing but well I try I try but it's
hard it is a hard thing because because
I don't know people don't want to hear
certain messages from people apparently
it is always funny though because of in
the day I'm like why I'm a human and I'm
a mom and I'm a wife and I'm more than
just a singer you know so and I have you
know a mother for that I I I don't know
I feel like as a parent I'm explaining a
lot away every day and you know
especially our 10 and 16 year old
they're starting to ask us questions a
time
like my husband I read dinner and I was
like oh god they've never been
interested in politics before but now
they're afraid and I'm like like so it's
just second guessing the navigate ten
sixteen sixteen that's the whole range
right there well because she are 16 euro
I'll keep saying well I'm gonna vote in
two years like why why should I vote how
should I vote how do I know who to trust
or how you know all these questions that
even as an adult of her hard to
interesting thing is most kids vote as
their parents vote totally it's an
interesting I was not with them but it's
fine I mean I I think that's what's
great about living in our country and I
think that that's what I think that's
what's upsetting for you know whatever
political belief you are whatever faith
that's the most amazing thing about our
country I think that we need to focus on
more than anything is that although
we're all very different we have
different beliefs or whatever the fact
that we're able to have those is what's
outstanding and I don't and I think that
people focus so much it's like idle
hands you know are the devil's work and
it's like people are so I'm like are you
all that bored that you're just trying
to like I don't I don't understand
what's happening like like focus on the
positive focus on the the similarities
focus on the great change like I try to
not distract people so much as to give
them a higher level of things to talk
about
absolutely you know like did you know
that when one centimeter of your Laura
Cohen lives and works more microbes than
all the humans who have ever been born
see I try so yeah so that way now you're
not thinking of who you're gonna hate I
don't hate people right I just don't I
don't hate people I'm just like done
with them over the 15 years you've been
known to us has technology changed and
the production of music my god how you
now perform or record literally I feel
like especially in my career like from
the 15 years I've been doing like doing
this it has been dramatic changes
they've been dramatic changes every
couple years you know I remember when
Napster for
came out they were the devil do you not
that 35 I started in nineteen so you
know it's just what I remembered that
was like oh my god the end of you know
whatever and now streaming is a huge
thing and like we're embracing it and
we're just figuring it out like how it's
gonna go but it's always been you know I
had cassette tapes to CDs to an mp3 to
you know I'm saying now it's we're just
streaming like it's like it's just so
and I try and keep up
so you started a cassette tape you
didn't say a track see no I day we go a
track here we go we go back yeah my Paul
Abdul so so okay but that's how you how
you ingest music but how about in the
performing of music are there any
technologies and microphones or we're
mixing tables um no I mean I think we're
pretty I like a an organic vibe I mean
we throw in some like cool beats and
we've gone on toured like a DJ before
and there's some cool effects you can do
like with bullet mic effects and stuff
like that but I don't know I don't
really I like keeping it pretty organic
and just because I didn't people don't
come to you know I don't dance I don't
fly I'm not there's no fire like it was
like just man yeah so we try and make
things sound you know amazing live like
the music in the end the vocals we want
to really pierce through the the
atmosphere like in the crowd so I used
the word atmosphere I noticed that I'm
totally digging it yeah did you know
that Earth's atmosphere is to earth as
the skin of an apple is to an apple
what's that fin that is that fin dang
and you know we're messing that up right
now you know people you know we are
small within it so we think you can just
pollute it and who cares
ya know what are your thoughts on I know
this is you are supposed to be
surrounded but I'm curious with like
Tesla like with Elon Musk like doing the
whole Mars thing like saying we have to
be a multi planetarium like species to
survive do you agree with that yeah
often people who say we need to be a
multi-planet species to survive they're
imagining asteroid strike or a virus
that could take this out I'm not talking
about that I'm talking was just ruining
planet Earth ruined
so now here's so here's my rebuttal by
the way Stephen Hawking feels the same
way yeah should be then as did Carl
Sagan many thinkers in the past total
I'm not entirely on board with it okay
let me tell you why okay just for
practical reasons I'm so interested okay
for practical reasons we're not gonna
ship a billion people to Mars or any
number of people to Mars to not come
back unless we've kind of terraformed it
turned it in a great word terraforming
yeah turn Mars into Earth yeah okay but
consider the day we have the power of
geoengineering to turn Mars into Earth
then you're saying why don't you just
use that right here then we could just
turn earth back into earth yeah but see
I don't know do you think we're that
powerful I'm saying if you could do it
if you turn Mars into Earth you can turn
earth into earth no matter what you did
to earth this is all I'm saying well
what if they're just planning on going
to Mars and creating like a like not
what earth is but trying to point oh
yeah like a different version okay
that's fine then you're not doing it to
survive you're doing it because we don't
fit on this planet anymore yeah and we
ran out of resources and we need another
place to get resources and we got a
spill out we're abusing a lot yes so
it'd be the same thing as you move from
the cities to the suburbs we move from
Earth to the green suburban planets that
could happen I can imagine that yeah
yeah there because we need it to not
because this threat of death seeing I
see it is like well then I guess it's
our time well I'm like I don't think I
mean I'm all about like I love I'm
curious about all of it so I'm I'm
always interested like I want I love
watching documentaries on it like I I'm
fascinated by it
Oh anything dealing with like black
holes that galaxies like just there's so
much we don't know which I find
fascinating but at the same time to I'm
just like well if it just ends well I
guess we had our moment in history am I
allowed to ask you in front of cameras
yes do you use autotune
on records yeah yeah we don't do it live
but we definitely have used it on
records are two key you cannot do it
live yeah what'd you say
here comes out on the right people that
do concerts that have their own colas
yeah because I know who they are just
people in the closet about there no
there are people that auto tune live I
don't do that live I don't want to take
away from that emotional moment but when
it's on record I don't mind if I have I
love our performance and I'm like oh I
don't I don't know if I'm gonna nail
that again or if I even try it again and
I haven't nailed like there was just
everything was perfect but one thing I
don't want that one thing to ruin the
whole whole vibe so so I don't mind I
don't mind like using it sparingly but
we definitely don't use it a ton because
it's a major addition to the musician's
arsenal the single Georgian and it's in
it there are a lot of cool things you
can do I mean I know a lot of guys in
rap use them because it sounds cool like
oh that's when you okay we did a whole
program for Nova back when I was host of
a nova spin-off called Nova ScienceNOW
yeah I interviewed the guy who invented
auto-tune yeah and he was telling me
about what happens if you if you change
it you can manipulate it over the edge
and then it makes it funny
yeah kind of weird yeah right and which
can be cool so on this we did it on
medicine on this album he made it clear
that that was not the intent the intent
is to fix your note to be the proper
note it's not to dangle off the side of
the waterfall where all these extra
weird noises come from yeah and it's
also cool like cuz how we like okay
there's a song called medicine that's
where we use it like on medicine there's
this part that goes never give me huh
never give me lit and it and I sing it
but then there's this also part they
literally took my vocal and almost like
changed it manipulated it like an octave
lower and it's like this it sounds like
a man my mom was like who's the man on
your record it was like that's my voice
they just manipulated it so there's
really cool things you can do with it I
think at the end of the day if you're
not capable of doing it live then I
don't think you should maybe that's my
personal thing but but if it's like
gonna run a moment that was really
beautiful and like it you don't want to
change that moment that doesn't bother
me I just think it's cheating when they
do it at a live
show because why I think that's cheating
is for all of us that are working our
tails off and you know we might be
emotional in pitchy up at points that's
not fair because then people pretty
false advertisement you know pitchy yeah
wasn't me yeah like if you're pitchy
like you know if you're going for me and
you go oh you said it as though that's
like being [ __ ] you know oh yeah so
you'll get [ __ ]
that's that follows there's there's a
cause-and-effect it's a reaction to
every action but no it's I don't know
so I also understand you got a lullaby
for each of your two books I wrote a
lullaby for the next one I love
lullabies yeah it was when I was gonna
write a lullaby for each one and we
might still do it but the the Christmas
one which was the second one in the
river Oh series I actually did a full on
Christmas song for because we thought it
would be cool because there's not a lot
of original Christmas songs out there
you know we always are even on my
Christmas album there's you know a few
but I love that one but it's nice to do
something original every one so we did a
full on Christmas song for the second
book but there's a lullaby for the first
it's the song I seem to her when she was
a baby so the series the book series
begins with what words I mean this river
rose and the magical ill-advised the
first one okay River River rose and the
river rose and the magical alibi and
then it's River rose and the magical
Christmas okay and then we'll see more
yeah there's a whole series that I've
written we'd actually didn't plan on the
Christmas one it just came up my editor
I was like we can do that near right and
he was like aha because I really wanted
it to come out it's a fun age you know
for River rose the real River rose like
you know for Christmas so I thought it
would be cool
she loves it so it's kid-approved which
is hard to get good stamp it and it's
good yeah so so I so lullabies I think
it's scientifically demonstrated to be
soothing to babies I mean we do that
empirically but yeah I think you can
study brain patterns and what parts of
it it hits and it and it calms anxiety
the speaking voice like a smooth rather
than a like your voice compared to my
speaking voice
yours would be more soothing so you can
sing and I can speak and we can let you
on the road
I say the universe and I go the universe
yeah have you ever interviewed Blake
Shelton no no I haven't no y'all two
talk okay looks like we I want to do it
with y'all I'm just gonna laugh speaking
of Blake Shelton oh you know an advisor
to American Idol no what is your visor
to the voice of course I'm an advisor on
this current season and the next season
I'm a coach I'm my own I have my own
chair oh okay all right because the
voice you are not facing the performer
yeah you start off yeah with the blinds
which is amazing yeah as it should be
yeah that's actually how I started
singing because I sing classical stuff
and every time you'd go to a competition
they weren't allowed to see you so you'd
have to perform by I perform behind
screens for years you know it started
that what they had auditions for a
classical pianist and violinists and
things and orchestras were predominantly
men out of proportion with the number of
women who were competing and so the
value wares are picking men saying oh
that they play better in music and they
put a screen up and then the fraction of
land why don't ya so now it's it's a
thing yeah I mean it's there's a song
about that video killed the radio star
to like and there's a bit of about it
that I like about you know the blinds on
the voice is that you can't see them
it's not about it the aesthetics it's
about the true talent and merit of the
singer right so you're not only a
performing artist you're you engaged in
some social activism when you can and
when you can make that change and I from
what I read you're also a philanthropist
I mean I try and shed light on
organizations that I feel like need more
attention it's always funny because
being in the spotlight we get so much
attention and it's nice to use that for
something spread the love yeah and it's
nice to especially if you're passionate
about it like what were you passionate
about well I've worked a lot recently
I'm really into executes super schools
just because I did this it's funny I
didn't even know they existed and then
like I randomly did this event for them
and they haven't been around I think
2015 may be used when they start of it
but it's a really cool innovative
project of like really applying
life skills not just the core things in
in school and really setting up kids to
get them prepared for life and it's a
lot of that kind of innovation and
progressiveness that i that my mom you
know she started a school actually that
was a public school but you almost said
it was like a lottery to get in but um
and it was you know not having teachers
stick to exactly the tests and
everything because kids learn
differently and all kids are you know
some are more creative some are more
math based some are more you know so
we're all different and so it's really
cool how they're there they're trying to
be innovative in the sense of changing
this archaic system that our educational
system is so you became a singer not a
teacher but as a singer you're enabling
teaching I I could never be a teacher I
don't have the patience but I I respect
you're doing the next best thing I but I
respect them more than any other you
know vocation just because it's one that
you're not paid well and and you give so
much people are always like oh they get
three months off like no they don't they
don't get summers off they're all in
there oh gosh where they call their work
in their workshops
my mom had workshops all summer they had
so they're always constantly working and
in there and they're it's funny because
we were all those kids in these
classrooms and like we go off and we're
successful make all this money and like
do all these things and these people
that are the reason why we've become who
we are and why we are successful are
working for nothing and giving
everything because it's not just my mom
especially and all the teachers she
worked with it wasn't just teaching them
those core subjects it's also teaching
them to be great human and it's also
teaching them social skills and how to
not be socially inept and act as a team
and and you know setting them up for
life and I just feel like we could do
better especially since we have four
kids I would like for us to do better to
get kids excited about it to apply it in
a way that is applicable after they get
out of school you know I don't know I I
really love to execute super schools I
think it's cool so you're from Tennessee
I'm from Texas but I've been in
Tennessee for over a decade for decade
okay so
you're a resident of Tennessee what part
of Texas Fort Worth Burleson it was a
bumper sticker I remember for my wife in
Texas yeah so we have roots there so
Tennessee your Tennessee resident yep
okay now I arranged to have a total
solar eclipse go completely through your
state actually Sumner County where our
farm is is exactly like one of the best
places so maybe my invitation was still
in the mail go back home and check it
was wood maybe it's still in the did you
have any like Astro person on your ranch
for this no we had no scientists on the
ranch you do I I love that I appear that
I have signs he's a scientist at arm's
reach well we do have chris died on our
team which he's a genius we call him
MacGyver on tour but he wasn't in
tennessee at the time yeah we we were
floored though it was one of the coolest
things I've ever been a part of followed
by a moon shadow
I was so steeped in darkness steeped in
darkness right that book right now sir
slick it seeped in darkness no I'm glad
you do you experienced it it's one of
the great spectacles of nature yes it
was it was amazing because once it
happened like literally the woods like
we have a lot of force and woods on our
land it came alive like all of a sudden
the locusts the crickets like everything
but everything was just like booming you
heard all the twilight creatures yes and
everyone was so quiet because we were
you know in all of what was happening
and then all the sudden we were like oh
my gosh I mean deer like things were
just coming alive and then it was
probably very confusing then it stopped
okay so the next time there's a total
solar eclipse over your farm you're
gonna call me up I will call you up I'm
gonna call you and you are gonna come
but I'm gonna call you you think
actually the next time to see it I think
is it where's the neck the next one they
said that was coming is it in 24
well there's it eclipsed every couple of
years so they're not as rare as the
press would have you believe right right
so and nowadays people with their we
have airplanes so yeah like there's one
like in South America like next year or
the year after 2019 and I think so
you're never really that far away from
the next one yeah
and lately by the way two-thirds of our
different two-thirds of our surfaces
ocean so there are entrepreneurial sort
of ocean people who say will sail our
boat into the Eclipse path and then you
have an ocean cruise the rest of the
time you're there oh yeah that's pretty
sexy yeah totally totally works
completely nice bottle of wine totally
yes total eclipse about WETA during the
eclipse all the songs I knew that
reference the total solar eclipse so you
should look it up there's some songs in
that know you can make you can make the
Eclipse album totally collaborate and
you hear that Atlantic Records that's
your next you could be like the you're
the voice so you're the sexy voice in
boys to men and I'll be the singer you
do that hey baby you just come in and
you just start talking about talk
science dirty talk nerdy to me
Kelly look West look with here comes the
moon shadow 1800 miles an hour yeah
[Laughter]
there's a cone through space of darkness
so took I'm glad you enjoy the Eclipse
I'm happy to have arranged it for you
thank you for every interview I conduct
I asked the person yes if because it's
not every day they're like hanging out
with an astrophysicist no I just wonder
if there's some question you have
harbored in yourself that you've never
had the right person around you to
answer about the universe this would be
that time okay I have one that you're
probably gonna think is silly but not
um I do i I have always wondered because
I have you ever had like astrology and
numerology or you know that kind of
stuff like have ever people do that to
you I mean obviously right all the time
yes and here's like silly mess but I'm
just saying teachers Annie all the time
you don't think there's any merit to
like maybe the season that you're born
in or do you think there's any weight in
that at all of like of like you know
what I'm saying like a time or like even
the emotional state of a mother if it's
a time of war time of you know whatever
it is do you think that any of that
plays out or its are like a tort being a
towards me at one's your birthday if
you're into the stuff then you should
just know hi so that's a great question
so holding aside all the stuff that is
summarily rejected by all scientific
experiment yeah you can imagine long ago
where if you're born in the spring or
the summer or the fall or the winter as
a child you would have different access
to nutrients of the food that grew on
the farm absolutely so if you were born
like the wrong time of the year you
might be a sickly child yeah and because
the food was already eaten or they were
spoiled by that or you're not ready so
you can imagine asserting before anyone
knew anything about nutrition think
about it we take vitamins because we
studied vitamins their Nobel Prizes for
each one of those vitamins that were
discovered okay they're modern things
you would have know about vitamins not
explicitly they knew some foods kept
your more healthy than other but go far
enough back you would say oh I was born
in February when the Sun was over here
therefore I will have this personality
trait so you can imagine circumstances
of nature and nurture come together that
could influence what kind of a person
you might end up being yeah okay but
that has nothing to do with the Sun Moon
and stars it has everything to do with
the nutrition of where and when you were
born I
right and so but let's go a little
further back you can imagine here you
are let's go back to Egypt and my lover
and the star and the star Sirius is
rising just before the Sun in the
morning sky dawn says and they say
because serious the star Sirius the dog
star is visible at this time of day
right in the early morning the Nile will
rise oh yeah it's Nazi trickery yeah you
you you you you're at the center of all
this moving
yes sky yeah so clearly the universe
knows about you yes and it's keeping you
healthy and it knows I need the Nile to
flood now so irrigation get centric a
few moons there it is it is so
egocentric yeah it and it's still
egocentric people saying Oh Mars is in
retrograde therefore my life is affected
by that you think Marvin you think Mars
gives a rat's ass about you no wait so
wait you see you're just you think like
with astrology it's more for like
mapping it out and finding your way and
is that what you in the day you think of
the Stars what do you think it are
helpful for us what do you think they're
there for like what do you you know I'm
saying like do you think people
navigated by them helpful yes yeah yeah
yeah but now they're not as helpful you
think they're pretty that's GPS yeah I
think they're scientifically interesting
and they're gorgeous yeah yeah so they
help people navigate and and I have
books where it says oh isn't it great
God put these stars in this way to help
me find my destination
again it's an assertion that the entire
universe you yeah and this is part of
the cosmic perspective will you learn no
the universe is not about you you're
about you yeah you have some control
over that yeah
but the universe is not about you and
the sooner you learn that the less your
ego will interfere with your domination
over others that you might feel that you
deserve yeah simply because you're at
Center and others aren't and then why
are you trying to dominate like what's
lacking yeah what is going on yeah yeah
it's like the older man with the sports
car you're like what do you mean
compensating for just at the time it
just so you know cuz I'm a guy so I have
to defend guys defend but let me explain
this away so a guy at middle-aged yes
has generally vastly more income than
when they were starting out so right
about when they might want the sports
car they actually have the money to
afford it and they're freaking out cuz
they're forty big I but I assure you at
age eighteen if they could have afforded
the sports car they would have yeah
without any reference would have always
been a talking the guys finally getting
the sports car they couldn't afford
earlier in all right stick up for weight
and I wanted to touch on something you
said I'm gonna go used to back in the
day of the nutrients and stuff like that
I find it interesting alchemy as
interesting like how science was always
super present without you know
unknowingly like just with like how they
use like for medicinal purposes like
other plants and although I think that
that's very interesting great point yeah
ok now chemists if you call them an
alchemists they'll fight you but but I
have a different view of alchemy sexier
name alchemy was the beginning of any
attempt to understand chemistry I agree
with that if you miss abusing nature
they kept good notes they said if I add
pitchblende
to this and I take salts to this and
they wrote it all out yeah and they just
were betting on the wrong horse that
they can turn one element into another
turned lead into gold
yeah iron into silver the turns out you
can't do that chemically but you can do
it in the nucleus you just went to
another level of we can take the atom
remove the electrons get down to the
nucleus toss out or add protons to the
nucleus and you have cosmic alchemy well
if you see God is having dominion over
atoms but if I take a rock and put it
from here to there are you saying I'm
playing God no you see I picked up the
rock and moved it twelve feet right
totally I just put
for whatnot but even so I'm saying even
metaphorically I have the strength to
pick up a rock and move it you're not
saying I'm playing God Wow now I have
the knowledge and the power to split an
atom yeah
to me that's no different than moving
the rock I get that's interacting with
nature this rock
[Laughter]
no I love that look I've just always
been interested in it because I think
that's just the basics of how science
was always present and I wish that I
would have been it was present no and
all of that when I was a kid like
knowing all those just helpful medicinal
things and those helpful medicinal
things not that was knowledge not
accessible to everyone
the shaman had that or the medicine man
yeah and sometimes they would know how
it worked but they wouldn't tell you and
that you come into the tent and there
they rub something on it would just be
magically dominated that was their way
and I can tell you as a scientist I will
tell you everything that we know that
gives us power over nature but if I
didn't tell you that oh my gosh we would
be complete in complete charge of the
world oh yeah if I say here you feel
like you are right now week into this
device yeah and I will transmit your
voice yeah to another place I'm so fired
then you hear your voice over there you
say oh my gosh how did you do that and I
will and I will not explain to
electricity and wires and in magnets and
awe and all the rest I could leave that
out and then you will come leaving gifts
at my doorstep yeah yeah so that's the
difference means science and magic in
science we we explain what we do yeah
you have to we do we want to yeah
because we want to bring everybody with
us yeah Kelly I wish I did
I have grown up with someone like you
around all of that thanks for being on
stage yes thank you and good luck with
the album
sometimes you need luck unfortunately
thank you you know what with the meaning
of life happy with the meaning of life
figured out so I can't lose can't lose
even if the album doesn't do well yeah
you know the meaning of what I know the
meaning of life so y'all is
any of my fingers I'm not a scientist
all right so good luck on the tour keep
it going thank you